we are a week into spring but still in
Winter's grip
snow has blanketed the south of the UK
with more to come further north an
unexpected bonus for some
and a nuisance for others caught in an
icy commute
Jesus Knight was the coldest of the Year
temperatures plunged to minus 15.4
degrees in kimbrace in Scotland on the
other side of the Atlantic cold air is
also sweeping across the United States
but in contrast Greenland has just had
record high temperatures with a capital
reaching 15.2 degrees well above the
March average of -5 so what's going on
well a major factor is a phenomenon
called sudden stratospheric warming that
happened three weeks ago 18 miles above
the Arctic the polar vortex a cyclone of
high altitude winds that hold cold air
in place above the Arctic weakened and
then reversed as the temperature in the
stratosphere Rose rapidly in just a few
days that's a natural event and happens
in two in every three years but
sometimes the impact are felt lower down
in the atmosphere where our weather is
generated remember the beast from the
East five years ago well that too had
his origins in sudden stratospheric
warming this time is caused a flip in
What's called the North Atlantic
oscillation resulting in high pressure
building over Greenland and Iceland it's
now bathed in warmer air than usual
which we've colored red meanwhile a wavy
jet stream has allowed cold polar air to
slip South into Europe and here in the
UK we're right on the border of that
cold air and warm wet air coming in from
the southwest where the two air masses
meet that moisture can fall as snow with
5 to 10 centimeters forecast across
large areas on Thursday and Friday and
up to 40 in the Pennine Hills
but it won't last long temperatures are
forecast to rise over the weekend though
Scotland hangs on to the chill for a bit
longer Thomas More Sky News